relates to a woman who's cooking during
the fast is she allowed to taste the
food as long as a person who's cooking
the food whether it be a gent cook or
lady cook there inkari volume number
three in the book of fasting chapter
number 25 it say Abbas he
narrated that tasting food from the pots
or meals it does not break the fast this
is a m of bukari but it is connected
along
with and and the chain goes on it makes
it sah and it says that Abbas please
with him he says that tasting vinegar
and food while fasting so all the Hadith
prove that while fasting a person can
taste food but you have to be careful
the food should not enter your throat
you should not swallow the food and that
is the reason the scholar say that if
it's required you should do it otherwise
not for example
Imam he says that tasting food is Mak
unless it's a necessity same
with he said that it is Mak unless it's
a necessity and while it's a necessity
if a woman is cooking food she has to
place the food on the tip of the tongue
so that she
realizes whether the food is sweet or
salty and then she should spit it out
she should not swallow it so that will
not break her fast or if a mother wants
to give food to the baby and the only
way she can give is by chewing it so
she's permitted to chew the food and
then give it to the baby but care should
be taken that they should not swallow
any particle of the food she should spit
it out so these are necessity where it's
permissible to taste food but
unnecessary just because you're feeling
hungry and you taste it it's Mak though
it will not break the fast makro is
discouraged it will not break the fast
but otherwise for necessity it can be
done but care should be taken it does
not go down the throat it should not be
swalled after tasting the food should be
spat out